What are some steps to deal with constipation? So I do have a something in your binder. I think
I think it's still in the binder. I wrote it a long time ago
I know I have a blog post them on a call because I remember the title of it called constipation know-how
So the main steps when you're dealing with constipation is never one with anything you want to go why why am I constipated, right?
Do I have a bowel obstruction? That's why I'm constipated. Well, okay
So if the person had colon cancer or abdominal cancer in at all
That's the first thing you do it to be concerned. Do I have a bowel obstruction?
You have to deal with that first you have to deal with the reason why and
The daily partly with the reason why let's say oh no
I have a breast cancer lung cancer something has nothing to do with my intestinal tract. It's all I'm constipated
well, is it due to
again, you know, I'm having
deficiency in
the production of
pancreatic enzymes or HCl which is the most common thing causing food to go into my
intestinal tract as a larger bolus. I'm having difficulty digesting. I'm not getting improper
improper breakdown of food improper digestion
is it
because of you know
Trying to dig into the because of why do I have an intestinal infection? Do I have a
Testinal bleeding do I have a testing digging through all these wise in a process called differential diagnosis, but let's say
That's not it. I just have some mild constipation once in a while
Maybe it's because of food that I'm eating. Could it be food that I'm eating that I do have antibodies against?
quote-a quote food allergies. Yes, all these things could be the case. Could I simply just have a magnesium deficiency?
Magnesium deficiency is actually quite common. Magnesium is a co-factor in just about
500 to a thousand different
enzymatic and metabolic functions in my body. We do use a lot of magnesium
And I have been doing a lot of sonas lately or I have been working out on the garden of the heat and sweating a lot
Maybe I do have a magnesium deficiency and then I am not having good bowel movement. So start with as far as supplemental wise
It's just taking some magnesium before you go to bed
And probably the best you could use any source magnesium magnesium glycinate magnesium
valent
You know two to four to six hundred milligrams before you go to bed with some water
Make sure you're not dehydrated too
So make sure you drink enough water that will help with constipation
If that's still not helping and I'm having worse problems with constipation
Then you move towards something like Cape Allo which I discussed in a previous question Cape Allo is a great
Product to help with constipation. Some people will use CETA
Except CETA can cause
How it works is it causes contractions of your intestinal muscles and that can cause cramps feel like cramping
So I like to use say Cape Allo. It's milder and it works like all the time
So those are the steps otherwise go back to the blog and look for constipation know how and you could
See some other things that you might want to investigate